And the answer is yes in all cases.
Now the clear cut case is the left one, which is the one we already discussed.
But we have data on a circle that could still be a main axis and
a secondary axis.
And PCA will actually give you a deterministic result, typically the
first X in this direction, second this direction.
The third one is surprising.
When we, remember regression,
it's impossible to build a regression that goes vertically because you
can't really divide this data set here as a function y equals f of x.
But regression treats the variables very asymmetrically.
One is the input, one is the output.
In PCA, all we get is vectors.
So I can easily imagine a coordinate system where the x axis falls vertically,
and the y axis goes to the left, and that's the answer for PCA in this case.